- Welcome back everybody.
We are here with Chrissy Teigen.
Give it up.
(audience applauds)
- Hello.
- So, Chrissy loves arcade
games, and well, who doesn't?
So, it's time to dominate her in a round.
- Oh.
- That's right.
- I'm going in bold.
- Excuse me.
- I'm going in strong.
- Ski ball showdown, y'all.
- [Chrissy] Whoa!
(upbeat music)
♪ Skee Ball Showdown ♪
- All right.
So, here to host, and make
sure there's no cheating.
- I see stretching going on.
- Yeah.
- Please welcome friend of the show,
Matt Iceman, everybody.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
Okay.
- The last time I saw Chrissy, by the way,
I was dressed as Cher in high heel boots,
and a leather thong teddy asking,
♪ Do you believe in life after love ♪
- "Lip Sync Battle."
- Is that a real thing?
- It was at a party,
it was "Lip Sync Battle."
- It was Lip Sync Battle."
- He was fantastic.
- Oh. Oh.
- I was like, "What kinda
parties do you throw?"
I was like, "And, why am I not invited?"
- It was a private party at my house.
- [Kelly] That's amazing. Oh, yeah.
- I forget.
- And, by the way.
- I won.
- Oh, yeah.
(audience applauds)
Kinda like how I'm about to do.
So, what's going on here?
Let us know.
- All right. This is Skee Ball Showdown.
Now, it's a basic game of skee ball.
- I can't not see you
in a thong right now.
- I know. Me neither.
(all laugh)
- This is a basic game of skee ball.
All right, ladies, you get
the most points, and you win.
But, here's the twist.
In order to be able to roll the ball
you must first answer a
trivia question correctly.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's hard enough to roll the ball.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, right, I know.
- Well, here's how it's gonna work.
I'm gonna ask you a trivia
question one at a time.
Here's a hint.
All the answers are based on games.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Now, you get it right,
you roll the ball, you rack up the points.
If you get it wrong, your
opponent doesn't have to steal.
Your opponent gets a free roll.
- [Kelly] Ooh.
- I don't know why I'm looking
at you when I say wrong.
(Chrissy and Kelly laugh)
I do get it wrong a lot.
- All right. Now, Chrissy.
- [Chrissy] Yeah.
- You're going to be playing
for the whole right side
- of the audience.
- Yay!
(audience cheers)
- All right. All right.
- Whatever, whatever.
- And, Kelly, you'll be
playing for the left side.
- Yes! Yes!
(audience cheers)
- Are you ready for Skee Ball Showdown!
- Yes.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- All right. So we
answer a question first?
- Yes. Question.
- Okay. Who's going first?
- Chrissy.
- Okay.
- Will be going first.
- Okay. The question first.
- And Chrissy, here is
your first question.
- Okay.
- The game with the mallet
whacking rodents is called
- Whack-a what?
- Ugh.
- Mole!
- Come one.
(bell dings, audience cheers)
- That's right.
- Roll that ball.
- Yes!
- Mine better be that easy.
- Should I keep it safe?
Should I go a hundred?
(ball clunks)
Ah!
- [Kelly] Okay. You got
points. You got points.
- [Chrissy] I just didn't want zero.
- I just didn't want zero.
- Yeah.
- [Matt] You are on the board.
Now, Kelly.
- Here's your question.
- Okay. Okay.
- Name three characters in Mario Cart.
- We just talked about this.
- Okay. Mario, Luigi, Princess Peach.
(bell dings, audience cheers)
- That is correct!
- [Kelly] What?
- [Matt] Kelly, it's your turn.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
(ball clunks)
- Oh!
- You're a risk taker though.
- She went for it all.
- I was trying to go higher.
- I know.
- Like usual she did come up short.
10 points.
(all laugh)
- That is, to be honest.
- It's 20 to 10.
- Alright.
- Okay, 20-10.
- They appreciate the effort.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Chrissy, here's your next question.
In what game does a circle
eat ghosts and little dots?
- Oh, Pac-Man.
- [Matt] That is correct!
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Or, Mrs. Pac-Man.
- Also correct!
- How inclusive.
- I like it.
- [Chrissy] Well, I wanna go all in too.
It's just for fun, right?
- [Kelly] Well, you're
already ahead of the game.
- Oh.
- So close.
- You're already
- [Kelly] ahead of the game.
You're already beating me.
- [Chrissie] Thank you.
- She's got 30.
- You might as well.
- Here we go.
What is the name of the
virtual reality game
where you slash beats of
music as they fly towards you?
- Beat Saber? Saber Beat?
Beat Saber.
(Bell dings)
- Beat Saber is correct!
- Yes! I love Beat Saber!
- [Chrissy] I've never heard of that.
- Oh my gosh. I'm gonna.
- [Chrissie] I would have missed that.
- Your whole family is gonna lose it.
- [Chrissy] Is it like Fruit Ninja?
- Dude, it's like you have.
- It is, but it's virtual.
You wear goggles.
- Yes. And you do these boxes,
and it's like they got music.
- It sounds like one of
those secret workout ones.
- It's good.
- And, I don't like that.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] It isn't because I do it, so.
(Chrissy and Kelly laugh)
Okay, here we go. Okay.
Okay. I'm going for it.
I'm going for it. Okay.
(ball clunks)
- Oh.
- Okay.
- [Kelly] I got more. I
got 20. Oh, we're tied!
- [Matt] A tie game.
(audience cheers)
- Oh, interesting.
- I like it.
This is a showdown for the ages.
(siren sounds)
- And that means in improbable fashion
that the judges could not
possibly have manipulated.
It's a tie!
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Wow. Wow.
- The Kelly Clarkson show
does not accept ties.
So, it is all gonna come down to
a simultaneous roll!
- Okay, okay,
(audience cheers)
- Skee Ball Showdown!
One roll to win it all.
Ladies, I will count you down.
Roll on my go.
- Okay.
- 3, 2, 1, roll.
(balls clunk)
- [Chrissy] Oh!
- [Kelly] What did I get? What did I get?
- [Chrissy] I got 10.
(Kelly screams)
(siren sounds and audience applauds)
- Kelly Clarkson, you won!
- I didn't even know!
I looked at yours, because I
didn't know where mine went!
(Kelly and Chrissy laugh)
- You deserved that.
- Yes!
(siren sounds)
- [Chrissy] She was fantastic.
- In improbable fashion.
(audience applauds)
Kelly Clarkson has won!
- Thank you, thank you.
But, at the arcade,
everyone is a winner, y'all.
Also, here at the Kelly
Clarkson show. Shocking.
So, "Dave & Busters" is the only spot
to eat, drink, play, and watch
in one place with
hundreds of arcade games,
40 foot TVs, ridiculously
good food and drinks.
And, everybody here will know firsthand,
because you are each
getting a $300 gift card
to "Dave & Busters!"
(audience applauds and cheers)